tell The Witcher
[Music]
[Applause]
can I have a little silence please I
tried to get some work done in here
thank you
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my video for The Witcher
Netflix movie announcement and what's
going on with season two so if you're
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the Witcher videos I will be
doing videos for the movie stuff when it
comes because that'll be separate from
the season two episodes I'll just break
all this down top ten style careful for
spoilers from The Witcher Season 1 I'll
be talking about the events of season 1
as I start talking about what's going on
during the movie that they just
announced and what's going on during
season 2 so number 10 WTF what's going
on what's this movie that they're
talking about so The Witcher Netflix
movie is called nightmare of the wolf
the wolf that they're referring to in
the title is obviously Geralt aka the
white wolf the people that make the
Witcher Netflix series are making a
tie-in anime movie that's gonna
crossover with the events of the show
and probably be released before season 2
gets here number 9 WTF the big
announcement they made about the
animation studio that Netflix partnered
with is Studio Mir they're the studio
created by some of the people who worked
on the original Avatar The Last
Airbender series in case you didn't know
Netflix is also doing a brand new Avatar
The Last Airbender series next year so
see how that's all connected those
people also went on to form their own
animation studio into the Legend of
Korra - so that's probably where most of
you know their work from in terms of
animation style so my early guesses
that'll look similar to some of the
animation on Avatar Legend of Korra but
be way more hardcore to make it feel
more like something you would expect
from a Witcher story and because it's
Netflix it's not being made for children
they can be as graphic as they want
hmm number 8 The Witcher nightmare of
the wolf official synopsis for the movie
is the world of The Witcher expands in
this anime film that explores a powerful
new threat facing the continent so
that's pretty brief it doesn't tell you
a lot about what the plot is going to be
but when they speak of expanding the
world of The Witcher with Geralt facing
a powerful new threat it sounds like
they're adapting a story that's not
completely told in the books and it also
sounds like a prequel story mostly I
think a service of not spoiling the
events of season 2 or future seasons
because I do think that season 2 is
gonna start right after the end of the
finale where Geralt meets ciri here if
you haven't read The Witcher books which
is what they're using to adapt the TV
show episodes season of storms is a good
example it's the most recent witcher
book that's been published but it's a
short story that takes place way earlier
in the timeline between the events of
the last wish after a guilt in yennefer
part ways like you see during The
Witcher Netflix episode 6 like she bolts
she's like that's it I've had enough of
you but the season of storms adventures
take place before sword of Destiny where
he and ciri come together like we saw
during the finale there's a lot of time
jumps in The Witcher Netflix series as
there are in the books so season of
storms just tells the story of his
adventures during those unexplained time
jumps the pacing is super brisk and
there's way more action in it then there
isn't some of the main books themselves
so number 7 my top picks for the
quote-unquote new threat that they're
actually covering during this Witcher
anime movie is season of storms the
actual book itself so quick synopsis of
what that book is about it treads a lot
of well-worn tropes of typical witcher
stories so you have kings and queens
that are a greedy and short-sighted you
have small towns that are corrupt and
suspicious everyday folk that are
prejudiced and violent worse than some
of the monsters Geralt is hired to fight
in at the same time Geralt conveniently
meets enough helpful intelligent
compassionate people along the way to
challenge his cynicism like he does
during The Witcher Netflix series so
like most of Geralt adventures that are
told in the books there's this constant
push-pull between his apathy for
Humanity and also his empathy because of
the good people he runs into the biggest
complaint that people have about it
though are that the stakes aren't quite
as big as you would expect because
the story takes place really early in
gerelds timeline so you kind of already
know what's going to be happening to him
later so even if he gets into trouble
when he's fighting a wizard
you know he's eventually going to
survive you know yennefer is gonna be
fine series going to be fine because
they all show up in the next book so
number six next pick is Geralt versus
sorrel de Gerland which is actually one
of the adventures during season of
storms one of the evil major antagonist
wizards he goes up against Geralt is
hired by a wizard to investigate after
there's a series of weird murders
happening in and around this mages tower
it's a castle called risen burg they
think one of their fellow mages sorrell
raised a demon and the demon has been
going around killing all these people
when Geralt finds him he thinks that the
demon merely possessed him and forced
him to commit all these atrocities so he
goes back but then finds out that it was
a ruse there was never a demon in this
evil mage actually created a couple of
troll hybrids to commit all the
atrocities so Geralt eventually has to
chase him down it takes him a little bit
longer but he eventually finds the mage
and winds up killing him number five my
next pick and I think this is a little
bit more likely is what the movie is
actually going to be about is the story
of what happened to care more in the
castle as it exists today is a ruin of
its former self
only vesemir lives there most of the
time there are other witcher's but most
of them are busy following the path like
Geralt engaged in monter hunting across
the continent so they live pretty low
Matic lives in the present day their
order is slowly dying off because they
can't create any new witcher's and the
old witches are slowly being killed off
through the action of their trade the
whole reason why they can't create new
witcher's to sustain their order is
because the arts and special potions
they use for the trial the grasses the
process of undergoing the Witcher
mutations were lost when the castle was
sacked by an angry mob the event is
never really covered in the books so
it's a prime candidate for some tie-in
material that crosses over with stuff on
the TV show sort of setting you up when
you arrive at Karrimor and during season
two so oh that's how it got to be like
this the reason why the angry mob was
able to defeat over sixty trained
witcher's at the height of their power
was because the mob also had the aid of
a small army of sorcerers and when it
comes to ranged combat and pure magic
your average sorcerer is a lot more
powerful than your average Witcher mages
like all cloth wearing classes are super
squishy though so in close physical
combat wishers would terasu than like
tissue paper but the castle was sacked
in the people at Kerr Moran who knew how
to make the special potions and create
new witchers were killed and their
existing supply of potions so like you
see Geralt creating a lot of potions
that's a big activity during the
videogames - he can create low level
potions but not the really special ones
that they use for the trial the grasses
those were meant to be very secret only
a couple people at any given time knew
how to create those and they were killed
off during that big attack I get a lot
of questions about ciri and her elder
bloodline because a lot of people that
play the video games see her being
trained to be a Witcher and they're like
well if she becomes a Witcher does that
mean that she can't have children and
the line will die off witcher's
themselves as they say during this
series are rendered sterile by the
mutations they undergo so they're
incapable having children the
old-fashioned way just like sorcerers
and sorceress is like yennefer tries to
find a way to undo that during the
episodes but because the special potions
were lost and they can't create new
witcher's so number 4 that's why you see
Geralt in the video games training ciri
at camera and later she grows up to kind
of be a Witcher of sores but not a true
Witcher the same way Geralt is she
doesn't undergo the mutations so she
still technically could have children
the thing about the books though because
the TV show is adapting the books and
there's still a ton of book story they
could go four five six seven seasons if
they wanted to I believe at the end of
the book story she's still technically
in her late 20s so a lot of the book
story leaves off with you just kind of
wondering what's going to happen to her
in the future so it's sort of left to
speculation but number three right now
The Witcher Netflix Season 2 is getting
ready to film episodes Henry Cavill is
getting back into shape I think they
start shooting sometime in the next
month or two they'll be making the anime
movie at the same time as they're making
season 2 episodes but the anime movie
will be released before season 2
episodes are ready The Witcher Netflix
showrunner did an interview a little
while ago explaining why they decided
not to release The Witcher Season 2
until 2021 because I think previously a
lot of us just assumed that they were
gonna release it at the end of this year
she said the biggest reason is just to
give them extra time to finish the
episodes in post-production like if you
remember Game of Thrones took way longer
to produce the final couple of seasons
because it was so many extra special
effects so there'll be a lot more news
and details about the season 2 episode
really soon but because the show is
following the books you don't need to
worry that much about what they're going
to be covering because they're just
gonna do the next book in the series
which is blood of elves I did a whole
big season two top ten predictions video
about what parts of the book I think
they're gonna adapt and what the Netflix
series is gonna change from the books
because they already changed a bunch of
the book story for season one so I'll
link that video at the end of this but
number two WTF for the most part season
two is gonna pick up right after this
moment here in The Witcher episode eight
ending where Geralt meets ciri in the
woods for the first time and she asked
him WTF is yennefer the whole reason why
she knows yennefer his name despite
never having met her seen her or ever
heard her name is because of series
elder blood power in the law of surprise
that binds her to Geralt caused her to
see him in her dreams that was what the
crazy dream sequence was all about he
was wandering around in the dark earlier
screaming yennefer x' name that psychic
connection is mostly because of the
elder blood magical power within her so
she doesn't actually know who yennefer
is she's just asking gerald who's that
chick you were just screaming about like
a madman when season two picks up
they'll probably head for camera and
search for yennefer on the battlefield
that sodden hill nearby since that's on
the path to care more n as far as I know
the Witcher Netflix Season 2 won't
release till at least a spring next year
maybe summer it's gonna take him a
little over a year to finish the
episodes so The Witcher Netflix anime
movie nightmare of the wolf is meant to
fill that gap so I'm expecting them to
release it at the very end of this year
but let me know in the comments what
story do you think they're gonna adapt
for Witcher nightmare of the wolf
there's a bunch of stuff coming up I'll
also be doing bonus videos for The
Witcher Netflix season 2 so leave all
your requests in the comments to
everyone click here for my new Witcher
Netflix season 2 top 10 predictions
video and click here for my brand-new
mandalorian season 2 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
you
Oh